المترجم: Aya AlAjjan
المدقّق: Ghalia Turki
عند نقطةٍ معينة،
لا يمكنك أن ترى نهاية الطريق،
تشعر بأن كل شيء قد انتهى، ووصلت
إلى طريق مسدود لا يمكنك تجاوزه.
تُرى، كيف حكمت بأنك لا تستطيع تجاوزه؟
هل حاولت مرةً أن تتخطاه؟
من منّا يعتبر أن الحوادث أو الأمراض
التي أصابتنا ستفيدنا؟
وتكون دافعاً لنا كي نبدأ وننطلق من جديد؟
وكم سنكون سعداء حين نتجاوزها ونتغلب عليها؟
كانت بداية القصة قبل امتحان
الثانوية العامة بشهرين
عندما تعرضت للحادث، كان هناك
بالصدفة شخصان يمشيان في المكان.
أسعفاني إلى المشفى، لكن للأسف،
عندما وصلت إلى المشفى
كان قلبي متوقفاً عن العمل،
وكل شيء قد انتهى.
بمعجزةٍ من رب العالمين، استطاع
الأطباء إعادتي إلى الحياة.
بقيت في المشفى قرابة شهر كامل،
خلال هذه الفترة استطعت استعادة
جزء بسيط من صحتي،
لكن هذا لا يمكنني من إعادة التقدم للامتحان
مما أدى إلى رسوبي.
كان شعوراً صعباً جداً لا يوصف ..
إنما في النهاية، كانت صحتي في تحسُّن،
وفكرت بما سيحصل،
وقررت أخيراً بأني يجب أن أحاول
التقدم للامتحان مجدداً في السنة القادمة.
بالفعل بدأ العام الدراسي
وفُتح باب التسجيل،
لكن المفاجأة كانت أن مقررات التعليم تغيرت،
مما يفرض علي أن ألتزم بالدوام في المدرسة،
وهذا ما لم أكن أفضل فعله أبداً نتيجةً
للوضع الذي أعيش فيه.
كان تحدياً كبيراً واختياراً صعباً،
لكنني قررت في النهاية أن أعود
وأدرس المقررات الجديدة،
وأداوم في مدرستي التي لا أعرف فيها أحداً،
لأن أغلب أصدقائي نجحوا وسجلوا في الجامعة.
بالفعل بدأ الدوام في المدرسة،
وخلال فترة الدوام لم أكن سعيداً أبداً،
كنت أشعر أنني في مكان غريب
لا يجب أن أكون فيه
حيث أن مكاني الأساسي
يجب أن يكون في الجامعة.
مر الوقت ببطء شديد
وبصعوبة غنيةٍ عن الذكر ..
لكنني في النهاية تقدمت للامتحان ونجحت،
وحصلت على مجموع 208 من 240 علامة
بمعدل 87%.
(تصفيق)
كنت سعيداً جداً في وقتها لكن في نفس اللحظة
لم أشعر بذات السعادة
لأن هذا المعدل لا يسمح لي
بدخول الكلية التي أتمناها،
لكنني لم أفقد الأمل أبداً
بسبب وجود فرصة أخرى
والتي هي "الدورة التكميلية".
كانت فرحةً كبيرة، وفرصةً
لا يمكن أن تعوّض أبداً.
جهزتُ نفسي كثيراً للامتحان
ودرست بشكل كبير،
وحان وقت الامتحان وتقدمت له
وحصلت على 231 من أصل 240 علامة
بمعدل 97%.
(تصفيق)
يسمح لي هذا المعدل بدخول أية كلية
أختارها في الجامعة،
ويسمح لي بدخول كلية الصيدلة التي
كنت أنوي التسجيل فيها،
لكني لم أحب ذلك القرار أبداً
حيث كان يدور في بالي خيارٌ بأن
أنجح فقط في الثانوية،
لأسجل في الكلية، وأوقف التسجيل،
لأنني بوضعي هذا لا يمكنني أن أداوم.
لم يوافقني عائلتي وأصدقائي
بهذا القرار إطلاقاً
فاستطاعوا بدعمهم وإصرارهم
أن يغيروا من رأيي.
وبالفعل تقدمت لكلية الصيدلة وبعد فترة
ظهرت نتائج المفاضلة،
وكانت المفاجأة الكبيرة بأن معدلات
القبول ارتفعت بشكل كبير،
وتم رفضي في كلية الصيدلة بجامعة البعث
بفارق 0.3 من المجموع،
أي أجزاء من العلامة ..
كما تم قبولي بكلية الصيدلة بجامعة حلب.
شعرت حينها أن هذا شبه مستحيل؛
كيف سأسافر وأعيش بمفردي وأبتعد عن عائلتي؟
وبالأساس سأداوم في كليةٍ
لا أعرف فيها أحداً،
لكن الخوف بعد ذلك زال
بسبب قرارٍ يسمح لطلاب جامعة حلب أن يداوموا
في أية جامعة يختارونها
نتيجةً للأوضاع السيئة في مدينة حلب.
بالفعل بدأ دوام الجامعة،
وواجهت الكثير من الصعوبات
من عدم تأهيل المباني على الإطلاق،
مع العلم أنه يوجد في نفس المبنى
مركز للمعالجة الفيزيائية
تابع لكلية العلوم الصحية.
مع ذلك، لم يكن مؤهلاً أبداً،
بسبب مشكلة وجود المخابر
في بعض الطوابق العليا.
أما المشكلة الأهم بالنسبة لي أنه لا يوجد
أحد من أصدقائي الذين أعرفهم معي.
تحديات كبيرة وصعوبات كثيرة،
بفضل الله، وبدعم من عائلتي وأصدقائي
الذين لا يمكن أن أنسى فضلهم أبداً،
تجاوزت السنة الأولى، والثانية، والثالثة
والآن أنا في السنة الرابعة وسأتخرج
قريباً بإذن الله.
(تصفيق)
خلال هذه الفترة انضممت لنادي تدريب
لكرة السلة.
في البداية كانت ممارسة هذه اللعبة
مجرد هوايةٍ بالنسبة لي،
وكنا نتدرب بتمرينٍ واحدٍ كل أسبوع
أو عشرة أيام.
بعد ذلك أحببتها كثيراً، وزدتُ تدريبي إلى
3 مرات في الأسبوع وأحياناً 4 مرات،
وأنا الآن لاعبٌ في منتخب حمص لكرة السلة.
(تصفيق)
في هذه الفترة أحببت أن أبدأ عملاً ما
أو أساعد بفعل أي شيء..
بالصدفة، أعلنت إحدى المنظمات
التي تهتم بالعمل الإنساني
عن حاجتها لأشخاص للعمل كمتطوعين
في اختصاص الصيدلة،
وتقدمت إليها فعلاً، لكن تم رفضي ..
تواصلت مع أحد الأطباء لأتدرب في صيدليته
وأزيد من خبرتي في هذا المجال،
وخلال فترة دوامي، أعلنت نفس المنظمة
للمرة الثانية
عن حاجتها لمتطوعين جدد في اختصاص الصيدلة.
وتقدمت هذه المرة إنما تم قبولي
ولله الحمد.
كل عقبةٍ في حياتي اعتبرتها مطبّاً
من الواجب تجاوزه وعدم الوقوف عنده أبداً،
لأنني مازلت في بداية الطريق.
لذلك، بودّي أن أقول شيئاً للمجتمع
الذي هو مجتمعنا،
أهلنا،
أصدقاؤنا،
وأقرباؤنا،
بأن الأشخاص الذين قدّر اللهُ لهم
أن تصيبهم هذه الحوادث
هم أشخاصٌ مثلك كمثلهم، لا تختلف عنهم بشيء،
إذا لم ترغب بالمساعدة، وأن تكون سنداً
لنا بعد رب العالمين،
كُفّ عن نظرتك السلبية..
وتأكد، وكن على يقين، بأن العجز الحقيقي ..
ليس عجز القلوب والإرادة --
(تصفيق)
وتأكد بأن العجز الحقيقي هو عجز الأبدان
وليس عجز القلوب والإرادة.
مللنا من هذا الحديث وكثرته، وكثرة
ما تداوله الناس عنه.
الفكرة الأهم التي أرغب بإيصالها هي
للأشخاص الذين أصابتهم هذه الحوادث:
ماذا تفكر أن تفعل؟ أقررت
على نفسك بأنك غير نافع؟
هل ستنتظر اليوم تلو الآخر
دون أن تقدم شيئاً؟
هل خطرَ لك مرةً أن تعتبر الوضع الذي
تعيش فيه تحدٍ بالنسبة لك؟
وكم ستكون سعيداً عند تجاوزه والتغلب عليه؟
عذرك جاهز دائماً، بأن "هذا المكان
ليس مكاناً للنجاح والإبداع،
مجتمعنا لا يقدم لنا شيئاً،
انظر ماذا فعلت بنا الأوضاع
وإلى أين أودت الظروف بنا".
أقول لك: يجب أن تكون
هذه الأعذار دافعاً شديداً لك
كي تبدأ وتنطلق من جديد،
ونبدأ بالتغيير بيدي ويدك،
لأننا مطالبون مثل غيرنا.
هناك كثير من الأمثلة عن أشخاص
تحدوا وضعهم وتغلبوا عليه
من عرب أو أجانب،
مع العلم أننا كمسلمين أو
أي شخصٍ يؤمن بأن الله
لا يختار لنا إلا الخير،
يجب أن نُضرب بنا المثل.
أمامك خياران:
إما أن تكمل حياتك محبطاً،
مستاءً وفاقداً لثقتك بنفسك،
أو أن تختار لنفسك طريق
النجاح وتبدأ من جديد.
الدنيا مليئة بالتحديات، والقرار بيدك،
إما أن تختار، أو تنهار ..
الإعاقة لم تكن يوماً نهاية العالم،
الإعاقة انطلاقة، ونقطة بداية.
حدد أهدافك واستعن بالله، ولا تعجز.
وشكراً.
(تصفيق)